steigen bald auch raketen von
deutschland aus in den himmel so
jedenfalls wünscht es sich der
bundesverband der deutschen industrie
bdi der einen eigenen zugang zum weltall
für deutschland als vision hat deutsche
unternehmen könnten so an der geplanten
kommerzialisierung der raumfahrt
teilnehmen doch es gibt fachleute die
die idee für einen deutschen spaceport
anzweifeln mit dabei der ehemalige
astronaut thomas reiter klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity klocke und dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen und vielen dank für diesen
coolen themenvorschlag von morpheus aus
unserer telegramm community dort bekommt
ihr unsere videos vor allen anderen
werbefrei und könnt mitdiskutieren und
themenvorschläge machen
der link ist hier unterm die positionen
des bundesverbandes der deutschen
industrie bdi ist eindeutig die
raumfahrt muss demnach deutlich höhere
summen an staatlichem geld bekommen
konkret geht es also unter anderem um
das finanzielle budget der deutschen
bundesregierung für raumfahrt derzeit
liegt es bei 285 millionen euro und soll
auf den handlungsempfehlungen des bdi
auf mehr als 700 millionen angehoben
werden nur so könnten deutsche
unternehmen an der geplanten
kommerzialisierung der raumfahrt
teilnehmen eine weitere forderung des
bdi die teilnahme einer deutschen
astronauten an den geplanten nasa flügen
zum mond zudem benötigt deutschland auch
dringend einen privaten weltraumhafen
von dem aus beispielsweise kleinen
satelliten starten könnten dazu der
präsident dieter kempf raumfahrt ist für
deutschland und seine industrie in
digitalen zeitalters von zentraler
bedeutung
die vorstellung eines eigenen
weltraumbahnhofs für deutschland ist
eigentlich wirklich nicht schlecht es
würde dem land als wissenschaftsstandort
gut tun und beispielsweise entsprechend
der hightech industrie als auch als
touristenattraktion wer solch ein
spaceport sicherlich was der
bundesverband der deutschen industrie
stellt sich vor kleine objekte mit hilfe
einer eigens in deutschland entwickelten
trägerrakete ins all zu schießen
durch einen eigenen spaceport mache man
sich in sachen kleinen satelliten
unabhängig von anderen der bdi betont
dabei aber auch dass dieser plan nicht
vorsieht konkurrenz zur europäischen
raketen wie der ariane klasse aufzubauen
die reaktion von
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
auf dem vorschlag eines deutschen
weltraumbahnhofs war positiv da zu sein
da in einem interview mit der bild
raumfahrt reißt viele menschen und
sichert tausende arbeitsplätze in
deutschland in der satelliten technik
sind wir führen deshalb werde ich den
vorschlag des friedens für ein werk am
bahnhof gerne prüfen
die bild titelt schon als mayer wird zum
allmayer andere fachleute wie
beispielsweise thomas reiter sehen das
ganze dagegen kritischer der ehemalige
astronaut bezweifelt dass sich
deutschland als standort für ein
weltraumbahnhof an bietet dazu sagte in
einem interview mit dem swr aktuell
es gibt in vielen europäischen ländern
bereits solche initiativen wenn man sich
die landkarte anschaut dann sieht man
dass portugal von den azoren hier
hervorragende bedingungen hätte aber
auch england kann sich reiter als guten
standort für einen weltraumbahnhof
vorstellen die auswahl des standortes
ist tatsächlich entscheidend um
raketenstarts gut über die bühne zu
bekommen
hohe priorität dabei menschen dürfen
nicht in gefahr gebracht werden der
start von raketen muss aus diesem grund
also weit weg von dicht besiedelten
gebieten stattfinden in mitteleuropa ist
deswegen kaum ein geeigneter standort
auszumachen in deutschland wäre dies
wenn überhaupt nur an der küste möglich
doch auch hier ist es laut thomas reiter
kaum möglich einen geeigneten start
korridor zu finden
optimistisch zeigt sich dagegen die
landesregierung von mecklenburg
vorpommern die im frühling diesen jahres
eine machbarkeitsstudie in auftrag
gegeben hat hier soll geprüft werden ob
der flughafen rostock laage als
künftiger weltraumbahnhof in frage
kommen könnte die technische
infrastruktur sei zum teil schon
vorhanden ebenso wie die
feuerlöschausrüstung auf der anderen
seite steht aber auch jetzt schon fest
wenn von hier aus satelliten in eine
polare umlaufbahn gebracht werden sollen
muss über besiedelten gebiet gezielt
werden das gleiche bei dem flughafen
nordholz an der nordsee hier kommt aber
noch erschwerend hinzu dass sich dieser
in direkter nähe des nationalparks
wattenmeer befindet und weil es sich
hierbei um einen unesco weltnaturerbe
handelt denen umweltschützer schon jetzt
auf die barrikaden die startplätze für
raketen auf der erde eignen sich
übrigens besser oder schlechter je
nachdem in welche umlaufbahn einer
rakete fliegen soll
möchte man die rakete auf eine
umlaufbahn um die polkappen
herumschicken sind startplätze im norden
und süden optimal soll eine rakete
dagegen in eine umlaufbahn nahe des
äquators gebracht werden sind los
fischer weise startplätze in der nähe
des äquators sinnvoll als beispiele kann
man hier indien und china nennen die
dafür günstige startplätze haben ebenso
wie der europäischen weltraumbahnhof in
kourou
die startrampe in florida liegt
optimalerweise am meer und in kasachstan
in einer fast menschenleere wüste so
dass hier herabstürzende teile keine
gefahr für menschen darstellen beim
start der in der nähe des äquators
stattfindet und bei dem die
entsprechende umlaufbahn angepeilt wird
kann sogar treibstoff gespart werden
denn hier wird die erdrotation genutzt
um geschwindigkeit aufzunehmen ein
weltraumbahnhof innerhalb der eu
jedenfalls ist keine neue idee und wird
schon seit jahren immer wieder
diskutiert im kommenden jahrzehnt
beispielsweise will die britische
raumfahrtagentur satelliten von
schottland aus in den erdorbit bringt
startplätze für kleine raketen in europa
sind auch im sinne von thomas reiter
wichtig ist dass man verstanden hat und
bei diesem geschäft mitmischen will
diverse unternehmen werden in den
kommenden jahren tausende kleiner
kommunikationssatelliten ins all
schießen
wir sehen und sie in konkurrenz besuchen
unternehmen sondern wollen gemeinsam mit
ihnen die notwendigen fähigkeiten
endlich wie hoch können wir bauen
anklicken also hier anschauen und
breaking lab abonnieren bis dann bleib
dran